hello we know why you are here you think
diffusion models are too slow and you
are tired of waiting for their unrushed
iterative generation process
are you asking yourself whether there is
a faster way than diffusion to do the
same job or are you happy to see us
covering research coming from normal
Academic Teams rather than huge teams
that openai Google or meta deepmind
great because no matter your reason for
clicking on this video we've got you
covered on many fronts today we are
going to explain how paella Works which
is a new way to generate images
conditioned on text without using
diffusion or Transformers paella runs
faster than diffusion and arguably is
conceptually easier to understand than
diffusion it also comes from a normal
academic team supported by stability AI
with compute though also Dominic the
first author of this paper does great
tutorials and explanations on YouTube to
check out his channel I'm sure you won't
regret it
okay so in this video Miss Coffee Bean
will give her best shot at explaining
paella but first let's thank creative
Fabrica the sponsor of today's video
since you are here watching this video
about research in AI art generating
models we think you might be interested
to try out creative Fabrica spark an AI
image generator that creates images that
are 100 unique just look at this
Whimsical Ultra cute Grinch in fairy
tale landscape pastel colors and so on
created by Sian Everson do you like what
you see great because you can try it out
yourself for free or with a monthly nine
dollars subscription if you choose the
subscription you get a thousand speed
credits that allow you to jump to the
top of the queue and even more users
with the subscription can also download
their own creation with the basic pod
license
so what are you waiting for check out
creative Fabrica by using our affiliate
link shown on the screen and in the
video description below and start
creating art from just text descriptions
okay it's still 2022 and if we think
about image generation we are not
thinking of Gans anymore but of
diffusion models such as Dali 2 or
stable diffusion imagine and so on for
more details on the fusion models check
out our previous videos or we are
thinking of Transformer based image
generation such as Dali 1. The outputs
of these models are amazing but they
come at a computational cost diffusion
models take hundreds of sampling steps
so of inference steps of the same unit
neural network to gradually paint
structure from noise so diffusion models
take a long time to produce an image for
the end user Transformer based image
generators have two problems as
Transformers usually work with sets of
vectors one must project the
two-dimensional images into vectors one
should not use too many vectors as a
representation for each image since the
computation time grows quadratically
with the number of vectors so with the
sequence length due to the
self-attention layers to generate an
image Transformers generate one such
image Vector at a time which takes a
while for more details on generating not
images but videos with Transformers
check out our previous video on finaki
that generates endless videos with
Transformers but this paper proposes
paella which employs another way to
generate images from text without
diffusion without Transformers but with
just good old convolutional neural
networks or cnns in short how does it do
it then the authors do the following
they take in the image and use a vqan to
represent the image in a lower
dimensional space VQ what don't worry
Miss Coffee Bean will explain the VQ Gan
in a nutshell the main idea of a VQ gun
is to take the image run it through an
encoder neural network in this case it's
CNN based to represent it in a lower
dimensional space you are correct to be
reminded of the latent diffusion models
because this is a trick the employer too
then a decoder neural network also see
an end base in this case takes the lower
dimensional representation and
reconstructs the image the encoder and
decoder are trained together in this
image reconstruction setting now what
about the quantization part well without
quantization the latent representation
of images would be dense and all
possible representations are allowed as
long as they are vectors in this lower
dimensional space in this example our
latent space is two-dimensional and the
axis stand for a different image but the
VQ gun says no let's not learn any
embedding let's just map everything to a
learned code book of a given size
so if the encoder says that this picture
lands around here the quantization steps
takes the nearest Vector from the
Learned code book here in red and the
signs it as a representation for this
image which we call a code word in this
way the decoder does not need to
reconstruct from any Vector in the space
but only from the code book vectors
which act like the centroids of the data
you can think of the VQ Gan as of an
autoencoder that also learns to Cluster
the data with nearest neighbors and
represent it with the centroids of the
cluster in the training procedure of the
VQ Gan the objective is to reconstruct
images to successfully do so we learn
the encoder weights the decoder weights
and what the optimal entries of this
code book are so for an image in three
channels of 256 times 256 the authors
learn a code word sized 32 by 32 times
256 so they represent an image which is
a stack of three larger matrices as a
stack of 256 smaller matrices now we
have a way to represent each image in
the Learned code book so in a meaningful
lower dimensional representation how to
generate images from text using this
code book the authors take the code word
of an image and noise out a fraction F
of the 256 small matrices so image
tokens representing it noising means
that they are taking another random code
word from the codebook to replace it in
other words they use the centroid of
another image token cluster then they
send the noise representation to paella
for denoising paella is CNN based and
not Transformer based like prior work
this has the advantage of being more
runtime efficient and can work with
larger inputs therefore the compression
into the code book does not have to be
that Stark so important details from the
image can be kept paella takes the noise
representation the number of steps in
the condition to denoise the latent
representation you have one guess for
what this condition is of course it is a
text representation coming from clipping
beddings it could be anything like class
labels or semantic segmentation Maps but
to do text conditioned image generation
the authors take the text run it through
Clips text Branch to get a text
representation and paella learns to
cross entropy to reproduce the
uncorrupted codewords of the image to
stick to the text information better it
also uses classifier free guidance if
you want to know what classifier free
guidance is check out our previous video
the reconstructed latent space
representation can run through the
decoder and so at the decoder output we
have an image conditioned on text during
inference to produce an image from just
text paella takes a code word of just
noise it could try to denoise everything
at once now but during training it has
never encountered the case of total
noise in the input so it would do quite
badly therefore it denoises the code
word in a sequence of eight steps steps
sound diffusion like but it is actually
more similar with masked language
modeling at each step the authors denies
everything but randomly renoids tokens
again to give the model a chance to
denoise these based on the already
predicted tokens if you think this is
very much like mask it in finaki which
we have seen in the last video you are
right the difference here is that the
authors do not use mask tokens but
random token sense because here at
inference we are still in the latent
space the decoder reconstructs the pixel
space of the represented image and this
was paella in a nutshell since paella
only contains convolutions and no
Transformers and other things it can do
latent space interpolation in paint
images so it can imagine what a hole in
an image might be filled with or do
structural editing the authors trained
it on 600 million images from the
improved lion 5B aesthetic like stable
diffusion also was trained on 64 Nvidia
a100s for two weeks with support from
stability AI for sure and you can judge
for yourself what you think of these
Generations or look at the author's FID
metrics which you know are not always
aligned to what humans think is a good
image
maybe these Generations are not what you
see from carefully prompted diffusion
models but keep in mind that paella is
relatively small in terms of numbers of
parameters compared to existing
diffusion models and need way less
sampling steps and it takes half a
second to generate an image
the authors provide all model weights of
paella together with a pytorch based
implementation in their GitHub
repository they even have a Google
collab and are on hugging face spaces so
you can just check them out now we are
leaving you with paella's version of the
cutest coffee bean there is and hope to
see you next time